sur twitter selon vous le bilan
économique de la présidence de jacques
chirac at il était positif et j'ai une
légère majorité à répondre non à 53%
quand on entend boris johnson
rendre hommage à jacques chirac en
français on peut se dire que ça a été
son c'était un petit peu le prélude qui
a inspiré david cameron par exemple avec
des référendum raté sur l'europe
ah oui c'est possible mais surtout on se
voit on se souvient d'un chirac n'avait
pas une grande affection pour les
dirigeants britanniques en souviens il y
avait notamment à lorient margaret
thatcher à la surnommer la ménagère la
ménagère et la présence d'hommes sur ce
plateau maintenant oui donc oui ça peut
être été un un aspirateur pour james
cameron david tiers monde par noël alors
sur le plan international il séquence
quand même qu'il restera plusieurs
séquences qui reste dans l'est dans les
esprits on parle bien sûr de la guerre
en irak
mais il ya également au tout début du
mandat cette séquence dans les vieilles
rues de jérusalem
[Musique]
depuis patrick on peut dire vous avez
été correspondant à jérusalem
jacques chirac avec son portrait dans
tous les magasins de la vieille ville de
jérusalem
vous devrez alors qu'elle était le
moment qui marquait de la prison chirac
soit au plan diplomatique moi c'était
celui là où chirac est devenu un héros
non seulement des palestiniens mais de
l'ensemble du monde arabe
dire qu'il va dans la vieille ville on
s'attend à cette rencontre extrêmement
tendue avec benyamin nétanyahou qui a
enterré le processus de paix alors que
on sortait des années rabhi nous voilà
il ya un espoir pour le proche orient
et là tout d'un coup on arrive à cette
liste on a l'impression que les
israéliens veulent tout faire pour
gâcher la visite de jacques chirac qui
est un des seuls présidents français
avoir traversé la vieille ville
c'est un parcours qui est assez
compliquée et la sécurité israélienne
empêche tous les commerçants tous les
goûts de tous les gens qui font des
courses dans la vieille ville de venir
saluer jacques chirac lui on s'est aimés
serré les mains et en fait ce coup de
sang a fait de lui un héros dans le
monde arabe et aujourd'hui encore il ya
une rue jacques chirac ramallah et on
parle de lui comme comme comme d'un
héros alors qu'il est président depuis
bien longtemps
quel bilan véritable maintenant au
niveau de la politique arabe de jacques
chirac
quel bilan n'y a pas il n'y a pas un
vrai bilan est ce que ces mêmes postures
c'est le symbole ou fait qu'il a eu
vraiment oui mais la posture et de
symboles qu'on beaucoup d'abord dans le
monde arabe
il ya aussi les relations personnelles
notamment avec hariri quand on voit son
revirement sur la civis et c'est quelque
chose qui a été totalement déclenchés
par l'assassinât de rafic hariri
et puis
il ya une présence alors il n'y a pas de
vrai bilan
de la politique arabe de jacques chirac
mais il ya juste un constat c'est à
l'époque la france existait dans le
monde arabe aujourd'hui elle est effacée
et parce qu'à l'époque c'est cette
politique de soin de proximité de coups
de sang de soutien certains dirigeants
de fidélité faisait que la france était
présente avait une influence on peut
plus dire là on peut plus vraiment le
cas aujourd'hui doivent notamment sur
sur un tas de dossiers notamment la
syrie elle est totalement marginalisée
les français ont senti nous dit brownie
tôt que la france avait encore une voix
et un poids sous la présidence chirac
il avait indéniablement quelque chose
oui évident que la position qu'il a
prise au moment de la seconde guerre du
golfe a été un moment fort
vraisemblablement est peut-être le plus
fort de son mandat parce que tout
simplement là en l'occurrence il s'est
inscrit dans une filiation qui pour le
coup était véritablement gaulliste et
donc il a dix ont été conformes à ce que
la doctrine diplomatique française telle
qu'elle avait été bâti dans le général
de gaulle finalement conseillé de faire
un chef de l'état donc je crois que oui
en effet là il a été il a été
indéniablement un homme qui a fait en
sorte que la france pèse sur la scène
internationale sa défense du multi du
multilatéralisme aussi est un autre
exemple d'une certaine manière de la
façon dont il concevait des relations
internationales je pense que il sera
vrai symbole est trop tôt pour faire le
bilan aujourd'hui de jacques chirac
parce qu'on n'a pas encore le recul
malheureusement nécessaire pour faire le
bilan de ces années là
mais si il y à un crédit immédiat à lui
porte et c'est peut-être plus sur sa
politique internationale quoique on
pourrait discuter notamment de
l'intervention de la france avec l'otan
au kosovo qui je veux dire la laisser
des traces en tout cas dans ce sens est
dans cette zone qui est pour certains
contestées mais globalement le la
politique en tout cas diplomatique de
jacques chirac est certainement la
politique internationale de jacques
chirac est certainement moins contesté
et moins contestable sur le fond que sa
politique intérieure qui elle laisse en
tout cas parfois dix ont un goût
un peu plus mitigé c'est en tout cas le
point de vue de nos internautes qui on a
demandé s'il était convaincu par le
bilan à l'international de l'ancien
président de la république et ils le
sont enfin tout cas ceux qui ont répondu
à 74% à ce que c'est votre avis
également
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'à
l'international il a il été visionnaire
sur certains points je pense que dans la
question de la laïcité de la neutralité
en termes religieuse qu'on aborde
aujourd'hui de plein fouet
il était déjà visionnaire parce que sont
les racines chrétiennes dans la
constitution européenne par exemple et
notamment par rapport à son amour de la
culture musulmane notamment et son envie
que la turquie puisse intégrer l'union
européenne il a été très courageux sur
cette posture là c'est peut-être ce qui
lui a valu d'ailleurs l'échec du
référendum de 2005 mais au moins ils
avaient pris position par rapport à des
positions complètement personnel ce qui
lui permettait d'être plus dur aussi
c'est que dans ce n'était pas très laïc
mais c'est aussi parce que ça reste un
engagement philosophique culturel qui
n'était pas politique du tout à ce
moment là et je pense que il a su avoir
aussi l'autre facette puisque c'est
quand même le président qui a changé la
doctrine nucléaire en permettant que
finalement ça ne soit plus une arme
exclusivement réservé aux gares
internationales mais aussi aux cas de
terrorisme contre la france et donc du
coup c'est grâce à lui qu'on a pu faire
évoluer cette doctrine qui savait très
bien distinguer son amour de la religion
est aussi sa guerre contre le
radicalisme
patrick saint paul sur justement la
héritage en matière de doctrine
nucléaire d'ailleurs 2
de jacques chirac qui a été contestée
dans les premières dans les premières
années de contester notamment quand il a
repris les essais nucléaires à mururoa
ça a été testée manifestations partout
dans le monde des manifestations partout
dans le monde et il s'est mis à dos un
certain nombre d'amis de la france
et pour revenir sur le refus irakien et
enfin d'intervenir en irak était perçu
par les américains comme un manque de
solidarité
il ya un autre moment qui a été
le celui du 11 septembre où chirac a été
le premier dirigeant du monde à aller à
new york
on se souvient des images de lui
survolant survolant new york en
hélicoptère et à ce moment là il a posé
un jalon en fait qui a permis le retour
de la france au sein de l'otan qui a été
de faire jouer c'est lui qui a demandé à
ce qu'on déclenche l'article 5 2 pour
pour qui la solidarité dès qu'on
intervienne au côté des états unis et
ensuite pour ça qu'ils ont une coalition
assez large contrairement à ce qui a été
le cas pour l'irak en afghanistan pour
l'intervention et sas a ouvert la voie
d'une certaine façon au retour de la
france dans l'otan qui a été ensuite
acté par nicolas sarkozy au niveau des
grandes institutions économiques
internationales
il a eu un rôle quand même moins fort
que nicolas sarkozy qui avait réussi à
mettre enfin avoir des français aux
familles mais ça y en a toujours eu mais
a gardé des personnalités bon comme
controversé communique ce procès nous
après déductions personnelles je pense
que ça ne l'intéressait mois il n'avait
pas partir au combat pour imposer un
français à la tête
ils ont l'air d'être d'accord avec moi
mais il a des yeux quand même celui là
il a beaucoup bataillé pour imposer
français à l'époque c'est vrai oui oui
oui alors ici d'être battu une fois
c'était moi - 2 c'était moi ces combats
la politique étrangère est le grand
succès de la présidence de jacques
chirac avec comme point d'orgue le nom à
george bush sur la guerre en irak en
2003 avec chirac la france étaient
respectées à l'international j'aimerais
qu'on finit sur ce plan là peut-être
patrick on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
avec ce que disait arnaud et quand même
plusieurs chiraco signal international
on parle du chef de 2003 on parle du
chirac dans les rues de jérusalem mais
on a eu quand même à chaque très pro
américain
dans l'est dans les deux premières
années de son mandat oui et puis ensuite
ils sont régulièrement kaka qui s'est
produit au moment de l'arrivée de notre
george w bush au pouvoir
et puis même temps dans les relations en
fait il était beaucoup d'idées à la fois
par des intuitions et par ses relations
personnelles avec un certain nombre de
dirigeants c'est quelqu'un qui
fonctionnait beaucoup elle affecte aussi
et mais qui voyait derrière toujours il
y avait une vision tout de même qui
était qui étaient associés et alex
schwazer par exemple la relation
franco-allemande a très mal commencé
avec helmut kohl qui après le départ de
son ami françois mitterrand était parti
soutenir edouard balladur on se souvient
de sa visite dans un chalet de balladur
à chamonix
donc évidemment chirac a très mal vécu
ce moment il ya une vraie réconciliation
autour d'une tête de veau et de bières
a strasbourg mais le courant est jamais
vraiment passé avec colle ensuite et
uche fraudeurs et schroeder lui au début
pareil ça se passait très mal il l'a
traité de marchands de voitures au
moment de la négociation du traité de
nice et ensuite tout d'un coup le
courant est passé et là il a su aussi
utilisé
schröder au moment de la cohabitation au
moment des conseils européens
s'asséchera d'heure je jure en parlais
tout à l'heure au téléphone qui ont
rappelé cette anecdote à la fin des
conseils européens quand il restait
fraudeurs chirac et jospin
schroeder disait à chirac disait à
schoder prends ton téléphone portable et
appelle doris doris c'était la femme
d'un milliard schroders et là il lui
parler pendant une demi heure au
téléphone alors que jospin attendait et
c'était pour montrer que voilà que cette
complicité qui existait entre lui et
chaudes heures n'existant à jamais avec
jospin garder jamais aussi il avait ce
sens de d'animal politique c'est à dire
que même dans les relations
internationales sa du service sur la
scène française et il utilisait tout
tout ça comme des armes pour régler ses
comptes aussi une certaine façon donc
gérard schröder vous a donné sa réaction
après la mort de jacques chirac
oui mais il était évidemment très triste
c'était un ami un vrai ami et puis après
c'est ce qu'illustre ça le mieux je
pensais après que je creuse heures
perdre le pouvoir
chirac était encore à l'elysée et
karachi trader a été invité à passer une
semaine
à la résidence marigny où il a déjeuné
tous les jours avec jacques chirac et où
jacques chirac penser à consacrer des
après midi entières à jouer avec la
fille de schröder et qu'il était au
pouvoir donc ça ça peut paraître un peu
étonnant pour censés gouverner la france
et en même temps on s'occupe de ces
zones mais c'était la fidélité de
jacques chirac à ses amis et bien c'est
sur cette anecdote que moi conclut à ce
point de vue spéciale sur la mort de
jacques chine